[Musique]
je m'appelle nathaniel tuvene deux ans
je fais du social depuis un an et demi
j'ai vécu dans l'hiver passé des fois ça
devient ça devient lourd de se
questionner à jour le jour parce que je
vais dormir qu'est ce que je vais manger
en général les gens choisissent pas la
rue les gens s'attroupent l'heure malgré
eux des gens se retrouvent en lien avec
comme sortes de situations qui leur
arrive maladie famille argent
j'ai demandé ce que je faisais beaucoup
ont accepté j'ai dû vraiment ce que je
me nourrissais pas du tout ou presque
content qu'à montréal il y avait quand
même pas mal d'organismes qui sont très
prompts à tendre la main
trouvé dans ton milieu qui te donner les
outils
[Musique]
j'entendais parler du cirque social
comme en malaisie où on va envoyer c'est
sûr
on aurait karine lavoie je suis à la
direction de cirque hors piste depuis
plusieurs années je pense que je suis
tout de suite tombé en amour avec les
arts du cirque à les dénoncer les
inégalités sociales c'est important puis
je trouvais que le cirque pouvais me
permettre de farce de façon créative les
zones conjointe à travers les activités
de cirque hors piste ont en gros entre
15 et 30 ans ça peut être des jeunes qui
vivent une situation d'itinérance une
problématique avec la toxicomanie des
défis au niveau de la santé mentale
souvent les jeunes avec qui on travaille
sont soit invisible ou soit perçue très
négativement par la communauté dont nous
au contraire on leur donne de la valeur
et on peut changer cette perception
l'autre ok vous vous mettez en comble
est que la personne la plus proche tu
m'appelleras blanc je suis instructeur
assure corpus contre avec l'expression
corporelle les théâtres le clown c'est à
peu près impossible de prouver quelque
chose dans le cirque it accroche puis
avec lesquels vous êtes à l'aise de
t'exprimer
le but final se transmet par contact
pour impôts
cirque en piste on veut que ce soit ce
qu'on appelle en safe space dans un
endroit où est ce que tout le monde se
sent accueilli se sent écouté ce sens en
sécurité en 3d avec des intervenants qui
vont aussi offrir du soutien et pour
toutes sortes de problématiques que nos
participants peuvent lire j'ai
rapidement perçu le cirque comme étant
quelque chose de bénéfique de positif
pour moi j'apprécie beaucoup mais
retrouver un gros pc voir mes amis je
m'appelle madeleine qui participera aux
dix années passées j'ai commencé à venir
aux ateliers
ouais j'aime beaucoup l'univers du
cirque univers un peu des enfants puis
de ceux qui on peut dire que c'est beau
chaque fois que je pratique un truc
depuis longtemps la première fois tu
réussis pour repère c'est là qu'est
cette question
[Musique]
je pense que ce que j'aime danser que
c'est tout pas aller chercher le petit
et le petit boost ou fabriquent nos
jeunes cherchent un peu cette adrénaline
de prendre des risques mais après ça
apprendre à savoir comment je peux gérer
ces risques d'alain côté addictif 5 de
vouloir tout le temps aller plus loin je
sors ton plaisir personnel pour réussir
tout en avoir le petit buzz âgées russes
pour la première fois puis ça permet de
rencontrer des gens qui consomment pas
dans des circonstances qui consomme pas
puis de toute façon ne peut pas faire du
sexe qu'on sait mieux parce que c'est de
pratiquer en même temps que le cirque à
me trouver un objectif qui est faisable
puis un coup j'ai approché mon objectif
mon trouver un nom au triste et en
mouvement rester actif
l'éditorial de maquillage c'est
important pour bloquer les parts
on s'est vraiment fait donner des
directives sur le look qu'on devait
avoir lieu pour raconter une histoire
pour mon personnage c'est pas nathaniel
mon personnage c'est autre chose
ce soir on a un spectacle tu as un
événement un 5 à 7 organisé par hors
piste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les montagnes russes de la vie ça monte
ça descend comme pendant tout le temps
je pense que les prix jour commune de
mon passage dans la vue sont vraiment
derrière moi je pense que je commence
bien équipé pour aller en montant pour
un bon bout puis pour descendre aussi
bas qu'en savoie
kaka qui devrait avoir des obstacles
dans mettre du béton